In this video, I'm going to teach you
everything you need to know in just six
minutes to write persuasive and
profitable copy. Before we dive in, make
sure to like the video and subscribe to
the channel. And that tells me that you
want me to make more insanely valuable
videos just like this. And make sure to
stay to the end because I have a free
gift for you that you're going to love.
All right, let's dive right in. First,
what is copywriting? Copywriting is
selling with words. The only metric that
matters in copywriting is sales. Did
this copy sell this product? That's it.
And if your job is to sell something,
then you as a copywriter need to
understand two things. The product that
you are selling and the people that you
are selling to. That is called product
to people fit. You have a product that
solves a problem and you are trying to
sell that product to a person that has
that problem. Your job as a copywriter
is to convince that person that your
product will solve that problem and
therefore they will buy your product.
And as simple as that sounds, it is
incredibly hard to do because there are
100,000
plus other brands and marketers out
there trying to sell similar products to
the same people. So, you have to
convince people why to buy from you and
not from them. Which is why now I'm
going to give you four key elements to
make your copy infinitely more
persuasive. If you have these four
elements, I guarantee that you beat any
copywriter that doesn't use these four
elements. Credit to Gary Benga. This is
his for framework. Number one is urgent
problem. Your copy needs to identify the
biggest and most urgent problem that
your reader has to get them to even be
interested in reading your copy. People
pay to solve pain. If you don't solve a
problem, you will not sell anything. And
the bigger the problem, the bigger the
paycheck. Number two is a unique
promise. You, as a copywriter, have to
clearly articulate how your product
uniquely solves their urgent problem. If
you don't have a unique angle to how you
solve their urgent problem, people won't
pay attention because they've heard it
before and it becomes noise to their
mind. So, the more different that your
unique promise is, the more likely
somebody will be curious to read your
copy. Number three is unquestionable
proof. You have to provide concrete
evidence with things like testimonials,
data, screenshots, case studies,
results, and even a live demonstration
to show that your product does what you
promise it will do. You have to make
your promise believable and undoubtable.
If somebody even has a smidge of doubt
about your promise, they will not buy
from you. And number four, a user
friendly proposition. You need to make
your reader an offer so good that they
feel stupid saying no. This could be a
limited time discount or a deadline
before the price increases or an
incredible amount of bonuses when they
buy before a certain time frame or a
money back guarantee that's so generous
it's crazy. Anything that makes your
reader say, "Wow, that's an incredible
deal." Now that you've got the four key
elements, I'm going to give you five
hacks that guarantee your reader gobbles
down every single word of copy that you
write. Hack number one, write to one
reader. You have to write to one reader
with one problem offering one solution.
90% of people should not get or
understand your copy, but the 10% of
people do will be immediately convinced
to whip out your wallet and buy your
stuff. When you try to write for
everyone, you end up writing for no one,
and generic copy loses every single
time. Hack number two, write
specifically. The more specific you are,
the stronger your copy is. The more
general you are, the less believable
your copy is. Don't say quick dry
shaving cream. Say dries in 60 seconds.
Don't say you'll lose weight and get
shredded. Say, "You'll lose 10 lbs and
have six-pack abs by the summer."
Specificity sells. Hack number three,
ask yourself, "So what?" Don't try and
sell your product. Sell what your
product does for your reader. You do
this by taking the features of your
product and saying, "So what?" Like the
classic iPod Steve Jobs example, instead
of saying 5 GB of storage, he said a,000
songs in your pocket. Because 5 GB of
storage, so what? Well, it's 1,000 songs
in your pocket. Say that. Hack number
four, have a conversation. Always talk
about you, the reader, not I, the
writer. Nobody gives a about you. They
only care about themselves. So, avoid
jargon. Stop trying to sound smart.
Pretend that you are sitting down at a
coffee shop with a friend and you are
simply telling them about a product
you're excited about and how it can help
solve their problem. And hack number
five, write simply. The shorter your
sentences, the easier to read. The
easier to read, they read a lot. Use
simple language that's one to two
syllables max. Never big words. And
lastly, break up your paragraph so it's
less overwhelming and it feels easier to
glide down the page. That's it. Those
are the five hacks, the four key
elements, people to product fit. You
have everything that you need right now
to write incredibly persuasive and
profitable copy. And as promised, I have
a gift for you. It is my copywriting
catalyst free guide. It has 63 cash cow
copywriting tips like these ones and
even better. Click the link in the
description below. Put your email in.
I'll send it to you right away
absolutely free and it's going to start
making you money ASAP. I appreciate it.
Again, like and subscribe if you haven't
already. Check out some of my other
videos. Read my daily emails. And I'm
glad to help you. I want to see you win.